[Music]
so I know certain amount of people are
gonna be watching this and going wait a
minute somehow he's Jason's either
selling out black people or or he's not
acknowledging racism and all that which
is it which is a perfect segue to what
got you in hot water last week you were
trending on Twitter which is Billy did
you know you were trying to solve oh
yeah you were trying out Twitter so you
said something about LeBron James and
racism let's let's go there and see if
we get in some more huh you want to go
in more hot water or less out like hot
water let's turn up thee so listen I
think LeBron James is well-intentioned I
think a lot of what LeBron James does is
excellent I think his work in Akron with
poor people and the people of his
community there is awesome I think that
what I'm trying to communicate to us as
African Americans is that we have to
adopt strategies that actually work in
the long term and even in the short term
and wallowing in any way in victimhood
particularly over hurt feelings or
name-calling because again it did he was
called allegedly on his gate the worst
name in my book you can be called yeah I
get it but at the end of the show
painted it on the gate outside yes
allegedly megiddo Your Honor it was
removed before the police got there by
LeBron staff by 6:30 in the morning they
had repainted this fence and the police
were handed a picture over okay I'm not
questioning the sincerity I'm just
telling you the facts yeah some people
are actually questioning that yes but
that aside that aside so again all at
the end of the day that's hurt feelings
LeBron's feelings were hurt his fare
there was no jeopardy it's the second
home they weren't there we don't even
know who the assailants were and so I'm
saying is as there was a time when our
victimhood was powerful and so you go
back to the 1960s
1950s when we were denied the right to
vote when we were denied to go into
schools when we were denied where we
could sit on a bus where we couldn't sit
in Stadium certainly when there was Jim
Crow segregation on the books true
victimhood didn't move people like
people would sit back and go man that
ain't right we got to fix that that's
unfair that's a human being and we're
denying them the same rights as everyone
else and so playing up our victimhood at
that point during the Martin Luther King
it was tremendous strategy and it worked
and it won us rights and so instead what
I've seen ever since the death of Martin
Luther King and Malcolm X is we as
African Americans first with and I'm not
I don't want to denigrate out Sharpton
and Jesse Jackson I just want to speak
flashily about am I
I actually know both of them have some
respect for both of them
but they came in and mimicked dr. King
when dr. King had won the battle for
Rights and that's all America promises
you right America does not promise you
your feelings will never be hurt America
doesn't promise you that people will
never call you a bad name the world
doesn't promise you that America's
Constitution promises you rights they
want us those rights
so our next leaders and our next
movement had to be about how do we take
advantage of these rights we've won
mm-hmm instead Jesse now and most of us
in african-americans we're still
mimicking dr. King and that movement and
think there's some rewards to be won by
playing up our victimhood and so to me
what I would have wanted LeBron James to
say and that moment was man this is
terrible
I it's a bad reflection on whoever the
idiot is that did that but trust me I'm
going to be fine and as
african-americans we need to understand
I'm so wealthy I can take care of this
there is some real discrimination that
goes on mostly with poor people of color
and mostly with poor people that's where
our energies need to be focused the drug
war mass incarceration
these issues have real impact we can't
be get overly emotional when some random
white person that we get that we think
is white yeah can't have that much
control over our happiness yeah do you
think we just simply ask too much of our
athletes that he this this thing
happened you know go if we go with the
official story that happened if this
thing happens we don't still don't know
who did it
but then the media starts talking about
it you know you say what you say
everyone on ESPN says what they say and
that further LeBron to do what you just
asked him to do it's like he's in the
middle of the finals right now they
don't want all these distractions and
it's like he's trying to you know his
team's down to O as we tape this he's
trying to figure that out and yet we go
to these people as if they're gods that
that are gonna solve all our problems
great point and it's another point I
agree with in terms of as I'm saying the
leadership civil rights leadership
needed to change our expectation for
athletes needed to change coming out of
the 1960s
Muhammad Ali never had a corporation
like Nike handing him I had a billion
dollars over the course of time right if
you put those puppet strings on Muhammad
Ali in the 1960s something Nabisco or
Pepsi or some tobacco company put their
hooks into Muhammad Ali for a half
billion dollars he would operate
completely differently and so our
expectations for athletes need to change
because their situation has changed
there's never going to be another
Muhammad Ali no how no way the the
financial rewards and again I'm someone
Dave I know here an atheist I grew up in
a small Baptist Church I'm a spiritual
person and believed in the things taught
in the Bible it's very hard for a rich
person no matter how great they are to
ever see the kingdom of God and the
point of that that's Matthew 19 24 the
point of that is you should probably be
a little suspicious of the wrist they
have so many demands on them that they
really it's hard for them
to keep it real for the poor and people
that are really disadvantaged it's not
because they're horrible people
since the demands on them make it real
real hard and so LeBron James
Muhammad Ali did well but he if the
Nation of Islam was in his pocketbook
the money in the 1960s wasn't nearly
what it is now and he was denied to
write the box for three years so he was
not a super wealthy person he was
basically mostly in the same boat as the
great mass of African Americans LeBron
James is not so it's very hard for him
to keep it 100% authentic to that group
of people now yet his heart can be there
he can remember what it was like for him
when he was poor but at the end of the
day the demands on him are such he just
can't be Muhammad Ali what I think it's
most interesting about that is you're
not making a judgment call on either one
of them as people know you're
acknowledging the reality yeah of you're
not saying Muhammad Ali would have acted
this way it's just a reality if someone
has a half a billion dollars coming to
him something's gonna change something's
gonna change doesn't mean you're
inherently evil or inherently good but
the ball has moved I think LeBron is a
great person
I think Muhammad Ali was a great person
I think LeBron is doing the best that he
can I think he is now surrounded by and
associated with some political people
and I don't trust political people he
when he started campaigning for Hillary
Clinton I like show me where Muhammad
Ali campaigning for anybody maybe he did
but certainly not in this prime right he
fought more for ideas yeah than a
candidate or a party yes and so when I
saw that ah and so when I saw his speech
last Wednesday I was like man that
smells like Bill Clinton that smells
like Bill Clinton said make them feel
you make them believe you feel their
pain LeBron that's the best thing you
can do in this moment and that's great
brand enhancement that's that's where
all these corporations right now wanna
be that you know we're for equality but
don't look at the Vietnamese people
we're paying a penny to make these
we're for equality just not in Vietnam
yeah right so tonight so tonight makes
the issues that we all have yeah I just
did Nike IDs myself so I've got them or
you know a lot of these athletes will
LeBron for example and again I'm not
judging for this specifically but you
know he'd to the sprite guy he does all
those spray-out Marshalls would heat
with his trainer ever tell him to drink
sprite of course not look man yeah take
all that high-fructose corn syrup
that's good for you Brian get a couple
of those in you before the big game Dave
I'm overweight we know what that stuff
does to all people but particularly poor
people and particularly
african-americans the soft drink
companies you know got us with diabetes
and high blood pressure and everything
else but yeah I'm not knocking wrong
make your money well but don't parade
around like you your actions are about
what's best for the poor and again he
may think that if I'm LeBron James and I
come out and say oh we're all in the
same boat and racism my life is terrible
because I'm black here at America it's
tough I don't know you didn't say
terrible it's tough and I'm like come on
man
your life is tough being an
african-american here to America with
all that money with all that you can do
for your family and free most people are
struggling living paycheck to paycheck
LeBron James I'm not knocking this is
great his best friend maverick Carter
before it maverick Carter madam Carter
quit college at like 21 22 because
LeBron made Nike give maverick a job
they paid him in the six figures and
that's a dream life that's not you know
I don't know where on the planet he's
going or where in the universe or in the
galaxy he's going where things are gonna
be much better yeah do you think that
this specific issue of taking athletes
and then thinking that they have to
represent the whole community or say
everything perfectly or all that that
this is actually unique to the black
community cuz I've noticed whenever a
black athlete or former athlete speaks
out and says something more in line of
the way you were talking so when Charles
Barkley is there some stuff about this
or Steven Naismith
has said some stuff about this anything
that sounds like it leans a little to
the right they get attacked mercilessly
I mean I clicked your name when I saw
the trend I clicked it and there were
there were thousands of people calling
for you to be fired calling you all
kinds of words that I'm not gonna say to
your face here I mean really terrible
stuff that for any of you guys that or
you know not just athletes people that
talk about sports you do anything that's
a little bit out of that and the assault
is is pre mercy it's a message to the
rest of the media and every other public
black public figure don't do because
mostly I'm uniquely I'm uniquely I don't
give an F and so you know I told someone
to start I told Colin Cowherd this story
the other day about my family we said
we'd have family get-togethers at the
holidays and as a five six year old
seven year old kid I would be preaching
to my family about what I thought they
were doing wrong or what we were doing
wrong and I didn't care that it bothered
people and so I don't care with people
over Twitter say about me but the
overwhelming majority of media members
and celebrities they do care who wants
to be bombarded with all that filth and
to have people and then sit there go all
my bosses my my kids my husband my wife
my mom and dad may go to my Twitter feed
and see people saying all this stuff
about me I just better stay away and be
quiet
because I don't want to subject myself
or my family too that it's silencing
people it's so people again what I keep
saying about Twitter has made media
celebrities and athletes we're all
politicians now and Twitter is our exit
polling and everything we say is is is
calculated thing well how is this gonna
land over Twitter am I gonna get
crucified for this someone will call me
an Uncle Tom or sellout and so people
don't say what they really think and
then what they do say is is
meant to get retweeted and loved over
Twitter and the biggest point I keep
trying to make is from Twitter to
Instagram to snapchat to Google to
Facebook this is all coming from San
Francisco and Silicon Valley and the
values and sensibilities that they have
in San Francisco are being pushed on the
media and celebrities through social
media all right so I'm glad you brought
this up because the first time we had
communicated you message me on on
Twitter and said something to this
effect that the values of the left and
the Liberals have been shifted from
traditionally being in New York they've
shifted to San Francisco so can you
explain that a little bit well I think
if people have been talking about him
the media's James and it has changed
New York used to control the media
everybody wanted to work in New York a
magazine newspaper TV you just if make
it to New York and so everything all the
serious journalism rewards came out of
New York or you know that far east coast
and so the traditional New York
working-class labor liberal mmm-hmm
was basically the values that were
reflected by the media it certainly had
a left-wing bias but to me New York
liberals are people that are trying to
perfect America hey America if we just
do this and this will be better yeah so
this would be like maybe like a JFK
liberal or a daniel patrick moynihan
liberal without question yeah eat and
I'll say I'll say this and people go
ahead to guys well Donald Trump like
liberal
and so but what do you mean by that what
do you let's not gloss over that because
I know you hit on it earlier but but
what not actually mean that if you
really look at what Donald Trump stands
for he's he's more in line with JFK than
Ronald Reagan without question you know
the guy could careless Pro gay marriage
I don't he's he's a social liberal yeah
his his friends are diverse he he as
long as you're willing to have a good
time Donald Trump's good with you yeah
he doesn't care
did you see that absurd fake outrage
when he had all those black business
leaders in the White House and Kellyanne
Conway I guess took these you either
took the picture of someone told you
actor and her foots on the couch and
everyone made it about that her being
disrespectful to the office I mean while
he's standing there with a ton of black
people who can have tremendous and do
have tremendous influence to change
things and somehow that's the part that
we forget about we're set about
Kellyanne Conway's foot so my point
yeah New York media was in control of
everything everyone catered their
perspective point of view to some degree
- please New York because everybody
wants to make in New York and make it
there the advent of social media and the
importance of going viral of being
retweeted in light of executives basing
their decisions on how many Twitter
followers do you have
we it's become a popularity contest and
whoever has the biggest following is the
greatest thing in the media and once
people figured out oh man I can rig
Twitter I can buy followers I can buy
retweets I can say certain things
because again when you talk about Google
Facebook Instagram Twitter the employee
base is all coming from San Francisco
and to me San Francisco is a different
kind of liberal it's a revolutionary
liberal the Black Panther Party is is
from there it's a liberal there's like
nah you know what America ain't right we
need to start all over from scratch
and I'm just not someone that wants to
start all over from scratch
I'm not someone who buys the narrative
that America is so bad and so evil that
it must be scrapped and started all over
again
America is incredibly flawed like
everybody else on the planet and America
has made really horrible mistakes but
America is also done in my view more
good than just about everybody else and
America again overcame slavery and
overcame Jim Crow to the point that
Oprah could do what she did President
Obama could do what he did Muhammad Ali
could do what he did I can do the little
bit that I'm doing and again it was an
ugly fight but we won some rights and
created some opportunities so I'm not
for blowing up America I'm for you know
perfecting and still trying to improve
America yeah well I always love talking
to someone from a different walk of life
that I agree with so much on a
philosophical level that we've there's a
lot of bad stuff here of course yes
there's a lot of good stuff and if we
can if the opportunity is equal then
that's what true equality is and that's
and that's what we have to always work
for but we've got more here than pretty
much anywhere else well look and we're
dealing with more diversity than just
about anybody else this is really the
melting pot and so people are like oh my
god
you know there's racism here but well of
course there is because we have more
people and again I say this all the time
I'm not defending racism I'm
acknowledging it and acknowledging the
fact that throughout the world's history
it's never not been here it's not going
away
people's minds will not be perfected on
this planet and so we can't control what
everyone thinks
and it's foolish to try to control and
to think that every white person whoever
it was that did this vandalism and
LeBrons how he we're probably not going
to fix that person and it's okay in a
way is that the real function of success
of a movement that the arc has bent to
justice so that we now look at little
things and blow them out of proportion
so again it's just as you're saying
you're not defending what the guy wrote
on the bronze gate of course not but
that is nothing compared to being hung
up by a tree or any or not having being
able to use the same water fountain so
it's a function of success you can't
make everything disappear but but here's
where I think things get dangerous and
because I want to be clear as people run
away whip out it's out here celebrating
Trump I really believe that this
irresponsible way that we talk about
race is why we have a reality TV star
sitting in the White House and that's
dangerous we shouldn't the world's most
powerful country shouldn't have a
reality TV star who's unqualified
sitting in the White House but because
of the way we have mishandled the racial
discussion in America it's created an
opportunity for someone like Donald
Trump in my view so I'm with you that
the trends of all of this are born out
of what's happening online and I've done
a couple videos about it and I even get
caught in it just this past weekend on
on Friday I tweeted I'm getting off the
grid and I put a little matrix picture
up I said I'm off the grid then I think
it was Saturday the the London attacks
happened and I and I heard about it
obviously just from flicking the TV and
from friends or whatever and I
immediately had this feeling like I had
to get back on there and say something
or I had to share my thoughts or
something and I didn't do it and I
fought every every impulse to do it
because I realized I'm one guy some
people look to me for some information
but if I can't just sit one out that
that is a huge problem for us personally
so we all have the personal burden of
this too in a weird way
i-i-i think without question what i've
done to my twitter feed is like if you
don't have a registered phone number or
email you just i don't see your tweets i
don't say that you can tweet at me but i
just don't see you yeah and i'm trying
to only do you feel that need though
that need to disconnect yes well no but
ali this need to disconnect but the need
to comment though so something happens
and then you know a certain amount
people are gonna look to you yes you
know even though you're a sports guy
they're gonna look to you and go well
what happened do you feel that need I
feel it but here's the what I've tried
to set up as my precedent and it you
know it's maybe a futile attempt but
I've my model with Twitter has always
been judge my columns enjoy my tweets
yeah and so far they don't even take
this serious it's really not now
when I go sit down to write a cow yeah
that's what I really believe Twitter is
what people think and there is a huge
disconnect between what we think and
what we believe I think I'm the best
looking man on the planet I think that
Halle Berry should be beaten down my
doors to date me do I really believe
that not really
and so we all think stupid things yeah I
mean anyway we also inappropriate things
we think racist things but do we believe
them a lot
your thoughts help develop what you
believe but you know a lot of the things
we think are we know are inappropriate
we know have no merit and but everyone
reacts to Twitter like it's someone's
belief and it's just not
you
[Music]